I got shot like a chump in the street for no
reason at all and next thing
i know i heard you calling me
i knew you needed me
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
Wandavision episode 6 video there were so many
easter eggs and references we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to my channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes i'm doing
Wandavision falcon and winter soldier episodes
loki everything that's coming this year this
is just the beginning we're doing the disney
plus giveaway for memberships all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite easter egg from the episode on the video
but careful for spoilers if you have not seen it
yet obviously i'm assuming you have if you're
watching this video we'll start at the beginning
of the episode and then i'll just number these as
we go along talking about easter eggs but this was
meant to be a bit of a cross between their 90s
and early 2000s episode because they were doing
mostly a malcolm in the middle parody during the
episode and that's kind of an early 2000s show
you also probably noticed in the recap at the
beginning of the episode or before the episode
started they played a clip of aaron taylor
johnson's quicksilver dying during avengers
age of ultron just to remind you about the
difference with evan peters quicksilver
there were actually several moments in the episode
where his character actually broke the fourth wall
so to speak at least within the context of the
hex episode like he knew that they were doing a
tv show in that everything was weird he knew
what scarlet witch was doing the whole time
i'll explain why that was when we get to those
parts of the episode because they were actually
pretty clear in explaining how he knew the things
he knew and why he was acting the way he was
it's not what people are thinking it's not some
crazy mephisto explainer it's way simpler than
that but they do a brand new version of the
intro scene it's all malcolm in the middle if
you've ever watched that show they filmed
most of the opening scenes of the episode
in a lot of the later moments in the same style
as the cinematography from malcolm in the middle
the zoom in on quicksilver's face the cutaway gags
even a lot of the jokes were done in the style of
the jokes that they did on malcolm in the middle
you notice as they're going through the different
family members agnes is considered one of the
family members like she's in their fridge and
she has naughty written on her butt which i think
is just another wink at the fact that she's agatha
harkness and there's more to her character she's
more complex than she seems in the episode so far
but the lyrics of the song also basically narrate
the action of what's happening in the episode and
how crazy things are getting they talk about not
fighting chaos don't question what you've done
the game can try to play us it talks about
everything being an illusion but don't stop
the fun then keep it going keep it going it just
keeps repeating that line keep it going then they
end on a line about not knowing who's coming to
play as quicksilver runs out inside the intro
scene so just a reference to his cameo during
the episode they have billy and tommy talking
directly to the camera just like malcolm did on
malcolm in the middle they make all kinds of jokes
about quicksilver being a vampire then everybody
starts coming down in their halloween costumes
the classic comic book versions of their halloween
costumes and they all wear the comic book costumes
it's actually pretty cool and pretty funny at the
same time the way they play it scarlet witch makes
a joke about someone being bleeding broken or on
fire that's a malcolm in the middle style joke but
obviously foreshadowing for the end of the episode
when vision is basically getting ripped apart at
the seams by the hex itself don't worry i'll
explain what was going on with that that was
a big moment but it has to do with the nature of
the hex and how everything is meant to work they
revealed way more about what's actually going on
than it seemed like they revealed in the episode
she says that she's a sokovian fortune teller
that's just a reference to them being romani in
the comics raised by fortune tellers the maximoffs
quicksilver does the funny cutaway gag to when
they were children in sokovia trying to trick or
treat and it seems like there's a war going on
behind them they play it up for a lot of comedy
like this looks like a terrible place to grow up
then they start that whole subplot with scarlet
witch questioning the nature of reality and not
being sure why quicksilver's different and why
everything seems different like the way he talks
about their backstory she doesn't remember
it that way why are you talking about that
it takes them to pretty much the end of the
episode before they fully answer that question
but early on when she starts questioning him
like wait a minute why are you different why
are things different he kind of blows past
it quickly without answering the question
the first time he says maybe you just repressed
all the traumatic memories of our childhood which
technically is not wrong so a lot of his dialogue
is actually commentary on what's actually going on
with her vision comes down in his classic comic
book costume claiming he didn't have any other
clothes in his closet because i mean the joke
there is the way scarlet witch made everything in
this new version of the hex set during the early
2000s she made it so that he didn't have any more
clothes and the look on his face lets you know
that he knows that she's changing things in their
fighting and billy kind of references later when
he's talking to the camera again mom and dad have
been kind of different lately part of it's just
follow-up on their big fight during episode five
him questioning the nature of this reality what's
really going on but also it's sort of a malcolm
in the middle reference because brian cranston's
father character on that show was always getting
into trouble getting into fights with the mother
but he actually does start a bit of a fight with
her they kind of get into it he challenges
her briefly i think the cane cola that they're
shotgunning there is just meant to be a joke about
off-brand coca-cola but you could also think of it
as a garrison kane reference he was a character
out of the deadpool comics he was also part of
weapon x and he was also part of the six-pack team
and you shotgun six-packs quicksilver steps in and
says he's going to be the father figure for the
night going trick-or-treating with them and then
makes a bunch of jokes about the pranks he's going
to pull with billy and tommy then super speed runs
out and back in with tommy both wearing classic
versions of the quicksilver comic book costume
with his hair done up like classic quicksilver the
reason why tommy is dressed like that is because
he's called speed in the comics he has powers just
like quicksilver and they actually manifest their
powers later in the episode too tommy's actual
comic book costume is green but it's based on the
original green quicksilver comic book costume i
think they just wanted to go with the blue costume
just because they thought that looked a little bit
better she jokes about turning him into a pickled
herring with her magic and that's just a callback
to the cutaway gag of them trick-or-treating and
getting the fish but also a reminder about her
reality warping powers because she could actually
literally turn him into a fish if she wanted to
back in the normal world they start analyzing
the 1980s stark tech drone that they had sent in
in the previous episode with the missile which is
still crackling with wanda's cosmic energy if
you didn't spot it in last week's episode it's
actually got a stark industries logo on it meaning
that they got a lot of their supplies in tech from
iron man and his father before him which makes
sense shield also got a lot of their tech from
stark industries tyler hayward is in the process
of going completely off the rails which he does
pretty spectacularly during the episode just as
fast as scarlet witch they're meant to be on these
parallel arcs like things are spiraling out of
control on the show and both of them are meant to
feel like antagonists like scarlet witch is kind
of an antagonist but she's also a good character
tyler hayward is also working for sword so
technically he's a good character but he's
acting kind of like a villain in the way he goes
on it actually sounds like hayward kind of hates
superheroes like he goes on about how he feels
like monica rambeau has been arguing on behalf
of super powered individuals as if it's a
bad thing like people with superpowers are
the enemies somehow and it sounds more like
something you'd hear from an x-men movie with
a character like trask being all anti-mutant so
this could be some more easter eggs and track work
that they're laying for future movies with mutants
and x-men characters in the mcu he references her
relationship with captain marvel and remember he's
going on and on about super powered people later
in the episode they give you another photon easter
egg when they reveal that monica's dna has been
rewritten completely by the hex they pretty much
tell her if she goes back in there she's going to
mutate quote unquote into something else which
i think we can all agree is them just setting
up her comic book powers he goes on and on about
how dark things got during the five year time jump
and i think that's more of a callback to his
conversation about how sword is an organization
now is more focused on developing sentient weapons
this is all about that vision storyline from
episode five too a lot of you were asking me you
know maybe he was trying to hijack vision's tech
and use his body for really bad things when
scarlet witch broke into sword to steal the body
and i think this is more confirmation of that
like he just goes on and on about how they did
everything they could to survive during that
five year time jump and i think part of the
reason why he didn't freak out when vision started
to get ripped apart at the end of the episode is
because he knows that vision is dead and he just
wants the body back he doesn't care about getting
vision back alive he probably just wants visions
technology i did think it was funny that when he
threw them out jimmy wu is the first one to call
the audible and knock the guard out with a punch
but then you go back into the hex and they're
trick-or-treating in the middle of the day
they're kids everywhere which is an answer to
vision's question about why there are no children
in west view except for billy and tommy and now
suddenly there are children everywhere quicksilver
actually straight up asks her at the end of the
episode but then kind of answers the question
himself the answer is the closer you get to the
center of town the center of the hex the more
active the people are inside the hex we know from
earlier episodes that there are over 3 000 people
total living in the area around the town but
the ones that live further out closer to the
barrier are less active and more like zombies or
drones and when she didn't need them for specific
bits that she was doing in the different decades
of sitcoms the different tropes and as quicksilver
says oh you keep them in their beds asleep no need
to traumatize them beyond the occasional holiday
cameo episode which is what this episode was a
holiday cameo episode because of his cameo so
what happens is for any given scenario or sitcom
trope that she's doing in an episode she activates
whichever townspeople she needs so if she doesn't
need people she just keeps them frozen or asleep
in their beds quicksilver makes a joke about
unleashing hell demon spawn as billy and tommy run
off just an easter egg reference for them being
soul shards of mephisto in the comics but like i
said the twist of the episode what's really going
on in the hex and how she's controlling everything
isn't quite so complicated as mephisto it's way
simpler than that she starts to question him like
she knows that something isn't quite right about
him and he calls it out like i know you're testing
me all of his dialogue here him talking about this
being shangri-la and claiming scarlet witch still
probably trying to forget things about her past
just let you know that he understands everything
that's happening inside here he calls out the fact
that he looks different but it's both a reference
to his halloween costume appearance versus his
normal evan peters look from just a couple minutes
ago in the episode and a reference to obviously
not looking like aaron taylor johnson quicksilver
then a lot of you probably caught this she makes a
kick-ass movie reference and if you don't remember
both aaron taylor johnson and evan peters played
friends in that movie together way before they
were ever in marvel movies very very meta but then
he super speeds off with billy and tommy to grab
more candy and cause all kinds of mischief then
they sort of set the bid up with herb he's talking
on the radio which is obviously a reminder that
they can talk to the sword agents via the radio
but the way they play the gag is a very malcolm
in the middle type of gag where he calls out the
action of what they're doing right before they
do it wait a minute all the pumpkins have been
smashed but then he tips her off about vision
lying about neighborhood watch duty and then also
makes a reference to her changing things with her
powers do you want something changed because herb
has been one of the few people inside westview
that we've known in previous episodes that
understands that they're really trapped there then
we get all the scenes with vision walking around
the outskirts of town much closer to the barrier
seeing all the people who aren't really active
they're just kind of standing in place or they're
repeating actions so they are conscious they kind
of understand what's going on but they can't break
free because scarlet witch's mental control over
them is so powerful the commercial this time is
all claymation i think it's supposed to be some
sort of yogurt commercial yo plate or something
like that but the yo magic brand is just a
reference to billy's wiccan powers because this is
the first episode where we see billy and tommy use
their powers for the first time but i believe in
future episodes as we see him continue to develop
his powers we'll see him do more crazy stuff along
with tommy you notice in the background the movies
that are playing at the theater this time are
the incredibles in lindsay lohan's version of
the parent trap the incredibles because it's the
early 2000s when that movie came out and when this
episode is supposed to be happening and the movie
is about a family full of people with superpowers
just like scarlet witch and visions family the
paratrap movie was from the late 90s so not the
exact same year but it's just a broader reference
to all of them being trapped inside the hex by
scarlet witch it's a metaphorical and literal
trap for parents as vision is trapped in the
hex like he'll die if he goes outside the hex then
quicksilver breaks the fourth wall again letting
you know that he knows he's inside an episode
of television i'm just trying to play my part
come to town stir up trouble give you some grief
she's totally confused has no idea how her power
brought him to the hex and then they asked each
other what happened to the sokovian accents so
many people were asking about this when the first
trailer started dropping at the end of last year
and early this year too before the episode started
how come she doesn't have an accent anymore
he says that all he remembers is getting shot in
the street during the events of avengers age of
ultron and in the sound of her voice calling to
him and i understood that you needed me so i came
i'll explain what that means in a second because
what's happening with quicksilver also explains
what's happening with vision but then tommy
reveals his super speed powers and they celebrate
later we also get billy using his superpowers too
but not till the end of the episode they make a
big deal about the twins not going past ellis
avenue which they then pay off later because
that's where the barrier of the hex is and the
whole reason why she doesn't want them to go
past there is because she thinks that they'll also
break down or somehow disappear if they go beyond
it but remember she doesn't understand how her
powers work so she's only afraid of what might
happen if they go past the barrier she doesn't
know what would happen they go back to darcy
hacking into sword and you get a better picture of
the shape and the size of the hex it's a literal
hexagon that's the whole reason why darcy started
calling it the hex but it's also a reference to
scarlet witch's hex powers in the comics they
find out about hayward tracking vision using his
vibranium decay signature because remember they
were keeping his body and it was all plugged into
sword systems so it seemed like they were trying
to use it to develop more artificial intelligence
weapons so it sounds like all he cares about is
just killing scarlet witch to stop what's going
on here this madness and then take vision's body
back and that's it but then you zoom in on vision
at the cul-de-sac and you see that because we're
so close to the barrier everyone is basically
catatonic just frozen in place by scarlet witch's
power we get the scene of him changing back to his
normal avengers costume floating up into the sky
going all superman to survey what's going on he
understands then sees agnes or agatha harkness's
car at ellis avenue she seems completely authentic
in this scene when she talks about the avengers
are you here to help us how come you don't know
about the avengers what's going on like she's
confused why vision doesn't know what's going
on we know from episode 5 that vision doesn't
remember anything before the events of Wandavision
episode 1 so that's why he has no memory of the
avengers and here's a better explainer for what's
going on with vision and what's really going on
with quicksilver the way they explain it during
the episode is that vision is dead and what we're
seeing here all of his thoughts his memories his
appearance is based on scarlet witch's memories
of him like you take her memory of vision then lay
that on top of his old broken body that's dead and
in pieces that she stole from the sword base then
she animates that with the powers of the hex so it
seems like he's come back to life but really she
just created a vision golem so everything about
him the way he acts his powers what he remembers
is all just based on her memories of him and what
she wants him to know so that's why he knows some
things like he knows that he has special powers
but he doesn't remember the avengers but mentally
because she's breaking down her ability to iron
out all the inconsistencies and little errors that
you spot in the episodes isn't so great that's
how you get to the evan peters quicksilver twist
quicksilver is essentially a quicksilver golem but
just looks different because she did a bad job at
creating him he's got some of her memories of her
brother that's why he remembers dying in avengers
age of ultron but has no other memories and the
stuff that he does talk about in the past doesn't
sound right because she's getting things wrong in
her own head she's blocking traumatic memories so
x-men mcu evan peters crossover quicksilver cameo
here is sort of like a botched golem that she just
did a really bad job of creating you also remember
that she can only re-skin other people so this
version of quicksilver is really somebody else
that she just turned into someone who looks like
evan peters side note that also confirms that it's
not a multiverse twist like he didn't jump from
another universe he didn't travel when she says
she called him she called him from her memories
then as darcy is hacking into more of swords
systems they set up the big photon twist this is
actually huge for monica rambeau's character you
see all these different medical files on people
i don't know if these numbers like they have a
bunch of numbered files those could be easter eggs
but the big photon monica rambeau referenced darcy
drops is her talking about her changing her dna on
a cellular level the hex if you go back in you've
already been changed twice if you get changed
again who knows what you're gonna mutate into
clearly set up for her getting her photon powers
then monica rambeau also gets a call from the
guy she says she was talking to back in episode
five the engineer who is going to help her build
something to get back in so this just confirms
that it was a male character and hopefully will
meet them during episode 7. so many theories about
who it could be i would love for it to be the blue
marvel but it could be anybody at this point then
for those either holding out hope for a magneto
cameo on the show at some point quicksilver makes
a reference to their mother and father loving
this place you could take that as a reference
to the maximoff parents or you could take it as
a reference to magneto and magna their biological
parents from the comics and she comes clean
like i have no idea what's going on he makes the
reference to holiday cameo episodes so like i said
earlier the reason why he knows all these things
is because he has her memories he's built from her
memories so when she says all she remembers before
the events of episode 1 is that she felt alone
she created the hex so that she would not be alone
so she's kind of talking to herself here and it's
almost the same thing with vision as well just
like the theme song said at the beginning of the
episode it's all chaos it's all an illusion but
just keep it going keep it going enjoy the show
this way when she looks away then looks back and
sees quicksilver all riddled with bullets in the
same place that he got shot during avengers age of
ultron is because he's completely fabricated from
her memories the place that she called him from
was her memories i know people are expecting a big
multiverse twist and it's really meta because it's
evan peters quicksilver and they're doing a lot of
classic x-men comic book quicksilver easter eggs
the show is meant to mess with you in that way
making you question the nature of this reality
when we go back to darcy and she pulls up more
names on her screen here these are all real life
people that work on the Wandavision production
staff or actors like james gad here this name
he's one of the editors alexander james i believe
is the name of the child actor who's playing billy
in the episode wiccan here you notice that she
uses jimmy woo's password and login to hack the
sword database again but when he steps out into
the real world you can start to see the illusion
wearing off like it's being ripped off of him so
to speak back into the hex because scarlet witch
was basically just re-skinning a dead body
and putting her memories into it to create
a vision golem like i said that's why at the end
of the episode you see him clumped over in a dead
body that looks exactly like he did when he died
during avengers infinity war because in reality
this whole time she's just been pulling off a
really elaborate weekend at bernie's plot but then
billy's powers manifest wiccans he actually stops
his brother tommy with his telekinesis you notice
that his energy is blue that he gives off instead
of red like scarlet witches but it's the exact
same powers he also has telepathy he runs to tell
scarlet witch dad's in trouble it sounds like he's
dying and then she freezes everything inside the
hex and expands the barrier to encompass him so
that her power will reanimate his body and bring
him back i love the way they go out on the episode
too you get that zoom out shot as tyler hayward
just barely escapes and everything is changing
around them so darcy is now a character inside the
hex it'll be fun to see who scarlet witch caster
has next week but pretty much everything here on
the outskirts turns into a circus which i think
is just another callback to them being romani
in the comics you get a much better look at the
actual size and shape of the hex it's enormous
but it's not covering the whole state of new
jersey yet it's just a much larger area beyond the
town but quicksilver is still there as far as we
know he hasn't gone away yet unless they wake up
in next week's episode and she's already changed
everything to fit the new scenario like nope
nothing wrong here just a case of the mondays i
think it's gonna be the modern family episode next
week but hopefully that explains what's really
going on with evan peters quicksilver showing up
as well as what's going on with vision and with
monica rambeau getting her photon powers if there
were any other big easter eggs or references in
the episode that you spotted that i didn't talk
about during the video just write them below in
the comments i will do a trailer video for episode
7 next and then some bonus videos let me know if
there's any really big bonus videos that you
want me to do because obviously they're still
raising a lot of questions and it's still meant
to be very confusing on purpose overall it was a
great episode i'm so happy that evan peters said
yes to coming back and playing quicksilver during
the episode even though like i said it was a very
twisty version of quicksilver the writers also
did explain a lot more about why they chose to do
quicksilver and why they did it this way you can
click here to learn all about that and click here
for my brand new falcon and winter soldier trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!